the lizzo of wine don't get wine I got
you
I'm going to be reviewing this wine with
all of you right now this is
a 2000
old hands Dustin my hands are not old
these are young Hands Old hands Shiraz
now I had this the other day
I've got to tell you it inspired me to
go back to my roots and make wine videos
for you Shiraz a very popular wine from
Australia normally but also I guess it's
a raw base and you see it from all over
the world what I love about these wines
is they're very very aromatic they have
a snippy sniff as
San Jose
sniffy slip time
and they're delicious and they're
explosive and they're bombastic they're
like the lizzo of wine it's about damn
time just [__] happy and epic [__]
brings it